what's a quasi-perfect number well a
perfect number is a number that's equal
to the sum of its proper divisors like
six its divisors are one two three
and six but that's not a proper divisor
one plus two plus three
equals six so six is a perfect number
a quasi-perfect number well that's a
number where the sum of the proper
divisors
is one more than the number itself
that's a quasi-perfect number only thing
is nobody's ever found any
but it's still an open question as to
whether or not there are
any and so as a high school student that
actually worked on that problem and
proved that
if there were any quasi-perfect numbers
lurking out there they had to at least
satisfy certain properties of all the
things like
there's all these glamorous things like
prime numbers and proper perfect numbers
why did you pick
this obscure little one that has this ah
well i was a student at a
national science foundation summer
program in mathematics that
though that was held at hampshire
college in massachusetts
and it was a wonderful six week program
and learned lots of math
and amongst other things one afternoon i
went to the hampshire college library
which didn't have that all many books on
mathematics but did have
some book on number theory and i pulled
out this book
and i found that i even remember there
was there was a description of
quasi-perfect numbers and
some result that had been proved about
them by someone called sierpinski
and we'd been talking about perfect
numbers and other things and i was
struck by that result and i wondered
could i do any better and it turned out
i could do somewhat better
and i ended up writing a westinghouse
prize contest paper about that the
westinghouse is now the
the intel prize and it ended up winning
the thing
but mostly what was cool to me was i
could see something in a textbook
and find that i could extend even by a
little bit about
what's kind of a relatively unimportant
subject
all of human knowledge by some tiny
little bit and once you learn that
that's kind of addictive
[Laughter]
oh i confess i don't even remember all
the details about what it was it's now
been
uh let's see you know more than 35 years
since i
proved that but it was a set of
constraints on
what the structure of the number was uh
i think it had to be
one more than a square and some other
things and how many prime factors
and the truth is i haven't followed
quasi-perfect numbers since then
it's probably not a really really
important question per se
although the question about the
distribution of divisors and their sums
that's a good and important question in
in number theory but it was more that it
was a
totally understandable tractable
question
that a high school student could
understand that wasn't hard to pose
the definition of it and to realize that
you could pose a definition in a
sentence
and that all the mathematicians in the
world still didn't know if there were
any
meant that there were just an infinite
number of really cool mysteries out
there
they were accessible in some way so
you know i loved mathematics for that as
a high school student i loved
mathematics i did my
undergraduate degree in pure mathematics
at princeton and my phd
in pure mathematics at and
you know just loved it i think so many
people love mathematics because
within your mind there is a world that
that you can create and experiment in
and find the regularities in and the
laws of without needing a laboratory
it's all accessible it doesn't seem the
default position for a high school
student to read about that
and then think let's nut out of proof
they're more likely to read that and
think oh i wonder if i can find one to
start taking stabs in the dark but you
went and made like a
a proper structured mathematical proof
well you know i think
i think the cool thing this particular
national science foundation program
that that i went to as high school
student had as its motto
find patterns make conjectures prove
things i think that sums up what
mathematics is about
and we gave emphasis to all of those so
i went there as a student then i went
back and taught for three summers as a
faculty member at it while i was in
college
teaching high school students about it
and i think all three have an equally
important role in mathematics finding
pattern
people non-mathematicians get the sense
that mathematics is this
really try and boring thing somebody
gives you a problem and ask you to
prove it or calculate a number or
something of course what mathematicians
really do
is they look for the regularities in the
world and the discoveries that get made
are the most interesting part of
mathematics then when you see a pattern
you don't quite know how to describe it
and phrase it and the act of phrasing a
conjecture
i believe that this pattern i i'm seeing
means
that there's an infinite number of twin
primes for example
or that there are no solutions that are
that all the solutions to a certain type
of equation uh which primes can be
written as the sum of two squares have a
certain form
learning how to take a pattern and turn
it into a rigorous conjecture
that's also an important work of
mathematicians and then finally when you
have a rigorous conjecture
figuring out how you could possibly
prove it and so
i think we learned most of all that that
was what mathematics was about and
therefore
when you saw something and there was a
conjecture about it you wanted to think
about how you might prove that
so yeah it was actually perfectly
natural for you know math kids i was a
math kid in new york city
i was a lower middle class kid from
brooklyn i had the opportunity to go to
stuyvesant high school in manhattan one
of the
one of new york city's absolutely free
public but exam schools
for math and science and uh
well i i loved it i got this divas in
high school in ninth grade discovered
there was this math team people meeting
at eight o'clock in the morning
it's i was in high school coming in an
hour before classes to get together to
do
problems and so the math team quickly
became a home for me i came in an hour
early went to the math team every day
over the course of four years eventually
became the captain of that math team and
in those those ancient
days before computers and the internet
or everything there was a special
trove of problems that
we had to work on and they were all
stored in the shopping bag
the stuyvesant high school math team had
the shopping bag
filled with problems and it was in the
care of the captain of the math team
that the shopping bag was kept
because you won this really prestigious
prize
because of these numbers i'm imagining
you feel some kind of
do you still find any kind of attachment
to it and like would you love to find
out if there is one or have you just
moved on now and it's like
well i mean it would be cool to find out
but i've i've moved on since there are
other things i'm fascinated by
[Music]
i think what was what was wonderful
about the
summer high school program was wonderful
about the westinghouse contest
what was wonderful about the stuyvesant
high school math team
was much more the community of people
who cared
what it really meant to me was there was
a life in this you could actually make a
living
you could actually have a community you
could actually have friends and
colleagues
who cared about deeply intellectual
problems and you know growing up where i
did
in the outskirts of brooklyn not
everybody
was like that and so for a student to
discover that there's a world of people
who care about such things
and live for such things whether it's
mathematics or biology
or mathematics and biology things i do
today
that was the real eye-opening thing and
if quasi-perfect numbers was a way to
get there that was great
but i don't necessarily have an
attachment to them but they were a
wonderful guide along the
along the trail you don't feel like you
owe them one no
no i think i think we're square do you
think there's one out there
what's your what's your gut tell you oh
goodness
um well
it's really tough i don't have a good
gut feeling on it i mean
you know i'd like to say there aren't
any because none have been found
but i don't think there's a tremendously
good
reason to believe there aren't any
the iphone which is gorgeous i love my
iphone
seems so important and directly valuable
but all the fundamental physics and the
electronics the computer science that
makes an iphone
possible they're crucial to the
existence of an iphone
and steve jobs would have said that and
tim cook at apple will say that
that the beautiful things you encounter
in your daily life
whether it's an iphone or a drug that'll
cure a disease